foreign
what are we doing here let's go on a
walk
hi Maya
yeah this bottle looks so aesthetic
it's Peach right
um
very much a drink I love Peach though
we're just chilling
sounds kind of weird not gonna lie
a light one
[Music]
we're going golfing
yeah
yeah we keep seeing these driving ranges
why not check it out
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Fortune
oh God something about death
in the thoughts of dying is broken God's
Mighty power
I might say I didn't think it was good
supposed to tie in
like this
oh I'm so good at this
there we go
I pulled too hard
and my cars now I don't know I can make
it
[Music]
it's so big how can I feel
oh
[Music]
no that was so quiet
no
[Music]
okay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I got a new surfboard
ah
I'm very excited
super happy with this right eggy maybe
uh maybe surf nerds will tell me off but
basically when my uh my longer board I
just find it so difficult to paddle out
if the waves are a little bigger you
can't really duck under the waves
because the the board is too big and
it's a pain in the neck I mean I I can
get out there but I'm exhausted by the
time I am and maybe they'll be like oh
your paddling's wrong I don't know but I
know I wasn't at the skill level to use
a short board yet so I think this is
like a good in between he said I should
be able to push this under the waves
I'm very happy with it I'm so excited to
try it out he told me some tricks too
which I'm excited to try out as well me
and Chris went to Chiba yesterday I
never surfed there before it was super
fun we went for three hours it was great
I'm gonna wax this bad boy
[Music]
12 degrees
it dropped from 30.
we're in a very rainy Ginza and we're
going to this art Art Aquarium
mine sets out in the TV show so we're
going to check it out
[Music]
what
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I love these guys
[Music]
look at this guy
shaking those things
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
that was really cool
better than I thought during games I
recommend it got the big boy camera out
today so hopefully getting some better
shots not good for longing though
Tokyo
for the rain in the dark
kinda love it we're going to check out
this um old building
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so ever since we got here like five
months ago you can only wear a t-shirt
because it's so hot and now I'm like
cold in a jacket since yesterday
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
era apartment block from 1932 and it was
supposed to be top of the line for its
time like having a shared public bath
inside and apparently you can go inside
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
technology I mean I guess we have a ton
of all the elevators in Sweden
what I'm not a guest today
I think it's just that we have
so cool
I like this
10 different a hat shop
I love that
I just want to look
foreign
[Music]
we're at a garden center that emergency
I found
seems pretty interesting
it's more like a Outdoor Center oh my
God they go hard
that's creepy yeah just chilling that is
an interesting Christmas tree
getting the spooky spirit
what I have in here
this is so pretty
you should take a photo happy Halloween
to me that is so creepy
I feel like if I saw that at night I'd
be freaked out
this is like the hanging guy
getting in the spirit now
my weakness in Japan to stop to serve
ice cream
this is chestnut what's up sir
um
that's good that's really good
that goes so well
[Music]
good
it's like a school trip going on kids
running around everywhere
we don't know where we're going we're
looking for the Halloween stuff you
found it she found it
well done
it's not gonna turn in
nah
that's a whole cluster of evil we found
the Halloween part oh my God
what is that
well that's cool
this is Japanese pumpkin patch
they don't really have it here
damn these are huge
getting the spirit
[Music]
it's too creepy I can't make this
oh cool you can see it from here
I've never been on one of these before
I love that Lawson it's like black
instead of blue this is so cool a lady's
just walking over traffic big deal but
it's a Vibe we're going to donkey shot
next to get some Halloween stuff
we think they'll have it there
good old me going down the best roads
you could go
looks like we're in the right place
that's gonna be me
it's all for girls
oh that was so cute what are you having
you happy daddy's home
huh
can I have it
no
can I have my slipper
thank you here you have Uber home
can I have the slipper
thank you
so I've been studying kanji this is what
learning 600 kanji's looked like
in the beginning I was like yeah just
write the same ones over and over
it's very relaxing so I'm learning it
from this book
which is really good Chris recommended
it and they sort of categorize the
kanji's into groups I've showed you this
before but I highly recommend it when
I've studied in kanji I added into this
database in Anki the Anki takes care of
the process of when I need to review it
so Anki thinks okay you need to review
this kanji now so I go through this
every day so breath is kind of weird you
draw a nose
sorry the stroke order was wrong uh and
then the heart
and that's a bread
Melancholy oh my God Melancholy is so
difficult I need to make sure I have
enough space so you're
head
I imagine your head is down
by your heart
is crowned
while you're away legs
are walking around
yeah
you have to be creative with some of
them I guess but my favorite kanji's are
the ones that like look funny like this
to me just looks like a face but it
means few if you add water to it it
means sand like few cents maybe if you
have a woman
and few it means Exquisite if you stop
and add few it looks so good I I feel
like I'm purposely drawing it more like
a person like it's not supposed to look
like that
uh that means to walk oh and yeah if you
draw walk and then shellfish it looks
like a dude just with a crown just
walking around it means VIP
so you kind of visualize this weird
story for yourself to memorize it and uh
yeah I'm at 600 now I feel like I know
them pretty well I mean I still have to
review every day and but I find it
really fun and relaxing I'm really
really enjoying it I always felt like I
had really bad memory but I'm learning
that it's not necessarily the case it's
more of the method that you use to learn
because it's so fun as well when you're
in Japan and you can
contextualize the countries in real life
and you just go what I know that you
know it's cool it's really fun anyway
just thought I wanted to share my
process I don't know if anyone cares
[Music]
17 years can you believe in Maya
that's not bad
huh
we're gonna go and celebrate Maya right
now look at this sweater I'm actually I
made her
do you love it man
I'm a turtle so these are all for dogs
and they have happy birthday cakes
oh wow 500 calories that's a lot for red
talk
I've never heard of a dog that's 17. oh
she's a good boy
you're gonna get food too like I don't
work a little appetizer
okay
okay there you go
okay let's see
bow bow
only because it's your birthday
what's that
what do we have there except for you
Maya
happy birthday
she loves him
foreign
[Music]
pieces for you
family yeah you look good
it's finally tolerable to be outside
it's really nice
you feel the autumn
hey they got Halloween stuff you happy
again
you happy for your sister she's going
for it
is she going up the stairs
[Music]
I come down and Mars has made a cake
you don't need to know
really good
it's a nice station Warren
really nice
I don't think I ever had it 10 out of
10.
[Music]
I say I got some Mount Fuji iron thing
you want to blow it up
whoa
that is bright
that is way more than I thought
whoa
that was awesome
well done that was great
let me show you guys my setup as you
guys know I'm a huge fan of Opera GX
even though it's technically
technically that should tell you how
much I love it I see my friends not use
Opera GX and I'd silently judge them
forever while other browsers lets you
change your background
Opera lets you fully customize
everything they have a ton of cool
themes and live animated backgrounds
they got a ton of Japanese live ones
anime Attack on Titan Hunter Hunter
Naruto one piece and if you use the link
in the description you get my Japanese
style live one as well looking nice it
also integrates with my keyboard and
mouse setup so whatever I click on it
automatically changes the color on it
that's pretty cool speaking of anime
they have a pop-out feature so whatever
you're watching you can move around
resize switch to monitors it's easy and
it works seamlessly if you use my link
in the description to download Opera GX
and reinstall it if you have it of
course which you do of course you get a
new GX Corner update that lets you see
all my latest uploads you know YouTube
likes to hide upload sometimes so it's a
great way to keep track thank you while
other browsers just bombard with a bunch
of pain that's super annoying and no one
wants to see that [ __ ] Opera GX actually
gives you updates on games new releases
and different genres I found a ton of
great games through GX corner it's
honestly so good I always recommend
downloading Opera GX on your mobile it
gives you the feature if you're watching
anything just hit the continue watching
button scan it with your phone and
you're on your way baby you can also
send files through your phone in your
computer and vice versa really easily
with my flow I also find that process to
be so awkward the email do you upload my
flow boom it's a seamless it's easy
Opera just has a ton of great features
like that they keep adding them as well
which is why I like it so much it's a
genuinely great browser I I think it
it's 100 the best one any opinion is
wrong other than that use my link to
download it even if you already have it
installed reinstall it get the new
wallpaper and get the new features and
yeah thank you Opera for sponsoring this
video